OK.
Let's go to the phones and see what's on folks
minds today.
A six one seven eight three zero forty seven
fifty is, of course, our number.
Let's start with our caller from the nine
one nine area code.
Who's calling today from nine one nine?
Or actually, that may be country code 91 is
is it cut this country code.
Ninety one make more sense.
Kella, country code.
Yes, that is you.
Who's this?
Oh, yes.
This is me, I'm I'm from India.
Two kids from India.
India.
OK, very good.
What's on your mind?
Yes.
So you know about that, the black man who's
who's had their police put his knee on and,
you know, he was killed on video.
Yes.
And you know what?
What happened was he just got fired.
You think there's any way that eventually
you will correct or whoever comes to a place
where he's people will actually be tried for
their crimes?
Well, you know, the I'm actually watching
a couple of documentaries right now about
the difficulty of getting guilty verdicts
for murder and manslaughter for police officers
who kill others in the line of duty.
And I mean, listen, the way our system works
is that you need.
To be convinced of guilt beyond a reasonable
doubt.
And one of the things about our system is
when you are a police officer and part of
your job is to assess so-called threats and
you use deadly force if you determine it necessary.
It is very easy for a good lawyer to introduce
some doubt and that according to our system,
reasonable doubt is all you need for, not
for a not guilty verdict.
And unfortunately, you know, even pointing
out this is a trained police officer who does
this for a living.
That is the basis for arguing.
We probably should doubt that they just went
out and committed murder, as we would call
it.
And so it's a structural reality of our system.
And that's what makes it very difficult to
get guilty verdicts for police killings.
Yeah, I just find it so weird that there's
a video of this guy like an individual, you
can see them precious Manhattans even I know
that he's just gonna get tired of this.
Yeah.
And a bunch of people writing with the same
feeling, people writing to me saying that,
you know, the the the father and son duo who
killed Ahmad are bery are unlikely to be found
guilty.
And yeah, I mean, I don't think people are
wrong in erring on the side of that being
the most likely outcome.
It's horrible.
Yes.
I just want to ask you of the song question.
Yeah, so the DOJ is using, you know, basically
decided not to investigate whether or not
this is over obligating.
How effective do you think is that for these
Republicans when they're talking with ideas,
debating Biden like you think it's effective,
as effective as being done?
Well, no, I. I don't believe it will be.
And part of the evidence is that the discussions
of Obama gate are already starting to fade.
I may be wrong, but a couple of days ago,
I checked for Google searches for it and they're
rapidly diminishing.
So I think the fact that you're hearing less
about it already is a sign that they realize
it's not going to have the cachet of Benghazi.
But I wouldn't be surprised to see them try
to focus on Hunter Biden.
That may be one that they're going to really
go all in on in the next couple of months.
We'll see.
Yeah, just like this.
I can't.
I don't want to see so much disparate information
in November.
I can't even imagine.
Yeah, it's going to be ugly.
All right, my friend, great to hear from you.
I think that's the first caller we've ever
gotten from from India.
I love it.